[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
la guerre des mixeurs comme dans le film
il y a plein d'ingrédients ici vous
allez pouvoir choisir 4 alors je vous
décris qu'est il y à des balades il a dû
chocolat en poudre
il ya je ne sais pas ce que c est la
marmelade il y à du sucre il ya une
mouche serrières dans quelle mesure il
ya des sardines il ya des verts il ya
des anchois
il ya des zones où il ya des oeufs c'est
à dire s'il ya des sous il ya du ca du
tabasco
c'est à du vinaigre je pense ça c'est
parce que c'est ça je sais pas ce que
c'est mais ses dreads ligue racicot
alors y'a tenir vous pouvez prendre
quatre ingrédients à chaque fois je vous
expliquer on va jouer à 5
celui qui fait le plus petit nombre a
perdu d'accord on y va voulais je
démarre mais qui choisir les ingrédients
abbas et vous après moi tous les jours
ensemble nous pouvons choisir quatre
celui qui paie celui qui fait le plus
petit doigt boire mais qui selon lui
prépare les quatre autres hockey est pas
un comic serait 80 gagnon et du jb à la
double un jeu démarche
on vient y en a eu alors celui-là mais
chez les autres qui disent ah moi c'est
on les connaît avec un peu de chance je
vais faire je vais faire un plus
passionnant non c'est mais ça c'est ça
ma chance ça je sais le s3 40 noeuds là
non c'est le plus non non on peut
repasser les images qui ont écouté le
plus petit qui va boire bon allez un
chacun on est parti attention c'est
parti non non non tanto chacun retour et
vous jouez normes chacun pour soi et les
moutons seront bien gardées comme moi
y'a même pas deux
m
[Applaudissements]
mais ça vient sceller la violence est un
peu tu la pression de façon bref c'est
vrai c'est même habituel chez moi alors
moi je ne suis pas dans la compétition
oui ce sont peut pas faire moins que toi
donc exigé pâturages montrer l'exemple
d'un show à ces jeux lançait ses frères
j'ai montré les gens pour la première
mais voilà alors qu'un du coin je suis
bien dans chaque âme est un ingrédient
d'accord vous êtes 4 à londres et c'est
parti vous mettez ici mais moi je met
direct mais insectes non non non tu pas
sûr non mais tout ça tu veux mettre mes
pas tout ça va dormir ne mange pas ça je
me dis maintenant pour prévenir d'avant
ce que n'ont ils pas de bananes la
famille c'est la famille les bananes et
peut-être un fluidifiant un peu d'eau
peut-être de l'eau c'est quoi sa taille
ne sais pas c'est quoi ça s'éduque au
café du coin c'est pas mal ça c'est pas
bon pour la ligne vraiment pour la ville
il reste à l'ingrédient costumés et
vinaigre non ça c'est pas cool non
même les [ __ ] et comme c'est
impossible au mixer moi je veux bien
mixée alors j'ai jamais mixer de ma vie
moi non plus quoique c'est là dans les
airs et une émission de télé pour blé
d'affronter les trucs très plaisant mais
qu'on peut nous montrer à quelqu'un je
tue ses mixes et appeler david guetta
réussit à dire qu'il faille
[Applaudissements]
la salle est chercheur qui n'était pas
branché ce besoin dort mal c'est pas
possible ça rigolait top itunes page
depuis belle avec aller
n'en rajoutez rien et on doit le faire
mais chéri à l'appât qui sait comment ça
va pas bien à boris vian mon chéri merci
merci la seule émission il ya rien qui
marche
non mais c'est ça y'a rien de marque ou
du courant je crois merci et merci à
mehdi agaléga et son stress de mehdi ça
va vous aviez vous l'avez testé un nom
mais ça se voit merci merci à c'est
parce que attendait il faut le vix et il
faut le a le b les gaffes cette garde je
crois qu'il faut mieux le mari allait
pas avec une sécu à l'ehpad comme par
hasard quand il fallait faire ça m'a
emballé mais qu'on annule cette séquence
allez allez
[Applaudissements]
ah merde l'auteur les batailles et parce
que moi je suis un pro du jus de fruits
pendant quelques secondes
c'est pas mal moi
c'est pas mal on remet un petit coup
quand même là c'est bon sens qu'avant on
s'en fait pas ça non ça c'est pas humain
[Applaudissements]
à
et puis est-ce que tu valides oui je
vais les trois patrons veut combien une
gorgée
c'est bien ça c'est sympa avec des vrais
morceaux d'insectes dedans
[Applaudissements]
les fabricants trois baudets j'ai un
deal s'est dit non mais je sais va t'en
tirer que finalement valeurs que moi la
votation au bar tard un deuxième
toulousaine c'est tout ce que je peux te
dire ouais je me pose une question
ouais est-ce que tu as pensé à mettre
des couches parce que là ce qui va se
passer
[Applaudissements]
non mais 30 juste élèves il faut bouazzi
prendre juste paraître sommes justes et
libres c'est ce que tu as dit à pato
charrette peur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alala la portion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la volée
il fait même genre ça va quand je vois
ça passe et tu as exactement pareil que
moi non plus hein parce que moi et ma
vie moi les vrais [ __ ] pris pour de
vrai bah tu commences à chialer parce
que c'était lui c'est dégueulasse assez
dégueulasse mais on va faire un deuxième
tour
l'évêque de vomir les jeux prennent
toujours très bien intelligent laura
sadis valoir sa mère des jeux des
tutorats trois tours y aura trois tours
si on pouvait aller le reste est
rapidement tombé les points sont au vert
sinon on les suit avec ta serviette si
tu veux voir vas-y mois essuyé à l'eva
du mont joux attention tu vois tout le
monde moi j'en ai marre de commencer tu
commences à parce que tu rejoues bah oui
grâce à ces courageux diaw
olalala choses du sexe à part bien
c'est que ça passe j'ai pas ce sera moi
sur un allez petit bout
ça arrivera
le refaire un repère nivard perdent il
va en reperdre bleus encore ok ok les
gars je suis chaud à les frérots
[Applaudissements]
alors on a on a 7 7 6 quand délégation
des fonds croit qu'on est bien m'arrête
non mais le kanak est cassé il part trop
tôt et si pour toi c'est six ans bah oui
un match si tu voyais ce qu'il a dans le
bide c'est qu'en plus mal du ventre en
ce moment c'est vrai je passe toujours
pas cher que les excuses là ça commence
bien par geci sabbath arrêter avec cette
musique bordel de merde
hitchcock souvient
la moyenne
c'est la moyenne voilà donc je passe
trois ou plus de 3 faire ils me
regardent 3 plus de 300 images vous
aider vous dites est un art et
malchanceux vote sommes sales et cyril
où
[Musique]
la wii
là on va s'amuser 4 radiant j'ai une
idée pour orly pourrait mettre sucre
chocolat banane on va choisir un on se
regarde un gagnant chacun dans des
chalets pour ton frère déjà choisis tu
chantes tu peux être bon évidemment
entre frères j'ai placé la barre haut et
qui prend le dessus voire malades
marmelade ça prendra le dessus c'est ton
frère
alors ça c'est très dur ça ça boit ça
nous on est passé sous la barre de la
même si tu veux aider ton frère pour la
marne la vallée alors attention
vas-y foncé du peut être aussi du gris
et du tabasco et oui tu peux le prendre
pas moi j'aime bien ça non
[Applaudissements]
c'est en effet ouais moi je suis obligé
d'être suffisant dit qu'ils aimaient
bien les filmer tout c'est ma mais dans
le temps l'eau de l'eau ça elle n'en
meurt pas avec ça on parle et qui a pu
aller non mais attends tu te fous de ma
gueule c'est la foudre mais les insectes
oh non est ce qu'on a le droit qu'on en
a le droit on se connait kg compris je
connais mon ami je sais que tu es mon
fort bah ça s'arrête là ce alors c'est
quoi tes la famille à la sardine
voilà ça va mais moi j'adore je mange
dessus de moi tout ça moi c'est vrai ben
non mais j'ai pas perdu quand même un
peu dégueu c'est pas la petite bête qui
a mangé la grosse bien des montures la
petite histoire comment savent pas
comment tu l'appelles soit humiliants et
ce manque de liquide un peu près ça
manque de mettre un peu d'eau de pluie
prend goût il est san iker alors un
petit peu de voix lasse assez gentil
mais j'aimais à cause de lui c'est son
film en direct c'est dans le film
mais d'anciens c'était vraiment
dégueulasse mais taquet tu vas être bien
toi allez je pense que les trucs bas
donc je prends ce ver a l'air pas mal
je tends mais combien tranquille
tranquille
voilà ça c'est bien ça c'est bien bien
sûr c'est pas marre alémany terreau à
les nettoyer
on peut y aller parce qu'on ne peut pas
mettre de plus ou alors mal et ne croyez
pas qu'on me dise où commencer
[Applaudissements]
sa part antoine aubin a passé
est ce que vous voulez un dernier tour
[Musique]
l'échec est
et
les shérifs proposé par la démission
c'est un dernier tour à huit un crayon
un dernier tour habitable et diam's est
encore toi qui perd un dernier tweet
ingrédients c'est parti à mener bolelli
alors ils ne sont pas trompés par
monsieur voulait la pac y venir et où il
veut participer
ah oui oui ouais attention
attention c'est parti attention c'est
parti 8 un gradient je le sens pas lui
au que je ne sens pas nuisibles ne sont
pas des zones de ces mecs et suzanne
hulot bon alors là c'est plus haut c'est
plus c'est moche l'aller pour moi mon
frère je lâche dayraut bizarre depuis
tout à l'heure on sait rien t'inquiète
pas que celle rccc c'est très bon
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Applaudissements]
l'éclat ya du lourd il ya du très lourd
plus grasse mais d un bras céder sa
portion ils sont tombés par terre
[Applaudissements]
il peut y avoir égalité sur ces chers il
peut la voir un gars du kenya la rega
les a laissés qu'il a gagné lycée qui la
gagne ou pas du tout et là il est
fair-play pas du tout un tas il a sa
technique séries tu veux et je te mets
10 ingrédients mais je tire un d'y aller
chez shaw a c'est pas mal ça c'est vous
l'acceptez licef là c'est beaucoup
d'ailleurs je dois faire plus de deux
secteurs pessin personne l'aurait fait
[Rires]
les mecs se respecte les invités déchiré
la prison je vais lancer ce des tu fais
plus de 2 10 ingrédients pour toi j'ai
fait moins de 2 c pour moi et toi autant
dé 8,8
on l'avait dit ce titre vous êtes tous
mes allées les séries on va se retrouver
dans un instant là une minute dans une
minute on va te retrouver je vais lancer
ce dès et ce sera parti
j'ai peur mais tu avais le risque je
prie pour toi si vous nous regardez si
son papa nous regardent et ben c'est
pour vous que j'ai fait ça a tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
syfy avec nous à lévis points comme mia
dvd qui est sorti libre 3 millions 600
mille ans reste un carton mon poussin
sur la semaine dernière la semaine
prochaine d'ailleurs et big flo et oli
et l'album et bien c'est décidé il est
formidable dire que je vous veux revoir
votre prestation de la fête de la
musique vérité forme établir sa nouvelle
soirée merci vous venez de lire le des
héros pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
attends je l indice est ce que je peux
est ce que je peux donner un gage en
plus haut ça va moi je respecte les
invités comme toi mais moins les
animateurs d'accord si ça tombe sur toi
ouais je rajoute ouais je choisis une
coupe de bananes pourquoi parce que sur
cette coupe de banane il ya une mouche
précédé allait décider parce que les
bananes à mon avis
allez allez panne et c'est dès la 6e'
elle est descendue dans les prés mon
avis les vivants ou généralisée ou tuera
jamais une mouche
nous avons décidé à petit non elle est
décidée regarde je peux la caresser non
non les douanes alors à l'epadesa a
décidé je connais je sais reconnaître
une mouche décédée n'est pas décédée
connais tu peux le dire
voilà le vol je connais tu peux les
décès les chéris ce que je propose c'est
que moi je dois faire avec un des plus
de 2 oui c'est exact
ce que je propose c'est qu'on prépare
d'abord la mixture 1
pas mal pas mal et qu'après je tiens
ferais tu vois c'est pas ma tasse ma
main alors auprès de marie comme ça on
va pouvoir se lâcher
je dois dire des ingrédients je propose
qu'on met tout de suite les oui pas mal
il réseau très bien c'est parce que
c'est eux ça fait bien des jeux s'est
bien fait de l'huile de foie de monde
allez vas-y vas-y viser les ingrédients
on met toujours un peu le madame sabri
joue du bien mère sera de mourir 3 c'est
parti bah nan moi c'est parfait
attendait et on choisit la région très
bien joué je suis allergique à la piste
a un coeur le piment ça fait toujours
prête à raison ces 5 4 avec des beautés
seul coup ça fait quoi ça me fait pas
mal de temps déjà qu'il s'était bloqué
la can algérien a eu un petit peu de
communes tout cas ça ne sera pas perdu
et le droit d'avoir perdu mais de
l'huile de nuit le recteur
mr je soutienne dexter
mais je suis vraiment pas bien là j'en
sais pas j'ai chéri j'ai un truc à vous
proposer
ouais comme dans quoi vous avez vu ce
que j'ai fait oui j'ai dit moi je le
fais un 10 qui est capable de faire la
même chose que moi
owni est ce que tu veux le faire aussi
maintenant c'est ton frère
mais bon ce que ça vous le but est comme
vous le faites à dos au but à 2 je sais
pourquoi je dis un truc
ouais j'aime beaucoup mon frère ouais
donc je vais pas le faire
seul un seul frère à la fraise en bas
franchement voler la vedette c'est hyper
je n'aimerais pas que ton frère tu auras
franchement c'est ça la fraternité
cheyrou bas merci à elle est belle votre
36 tu fais de il se passe quoi
si je fais deux sétois qui a perdu quoi
ben oui trouver les règles non il a fait
deux fois mais ouais mais ouais mais si
je fais deux non le faire en inde et non
non non service de neuro m'embobiner je
fais tous mes qualités
bon allez devoir faire d'accord ok merci
à notre tirage amd c'est impossible que
je gagne
fait un tintin tintin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut savoir savoir que pendant la
coupure il ya un mec de ton émission qui
essayait de me rassurer qui me fait
l'inquiète ya un saut pour vomir c'est
vrai c'est vrai nous revient c'est jean
s'est joué dans les mails raté alors les
chiroux attaquent-ils et qu'on calcule
pas s' attendait chaque quelque chose un
petit peu de promo pour l'album quand
même avant le mérite mieux et pour tous
ceux qui soutiennent nick fry au li na
s'est bougé remis à cuba
[Musique]
bon gardien
abba way you lie
non merci pas revenir remercie pour
l'invitation est vaste meriane plaisir
mais la vraie vie big three au lycée
l'album à l'est du pont comme et mon
prêtre en poussins ah lalala lalala les
chéris je suis très très content
vraiment de voir les chroniqueurs vous
savez pas dit bonjour merci d'être là ça
va les chevilles et les dernières
applications via la pac qui a toujours
joué avec moi sans déconner